the Gulf Rally was the fastest and no
doubt most exclusive Volkswagen of the
1980s the ultimate in automotive
development for the Gulf - which sold
six million units from 1983 to 92 the
rally version went on sale in 1989
they go as Christophe explains the Gulf
to made history as the very first
Volkswagen built pretty much entirely on
a fully automated assembly line but the
Gulf rally was an exception it was hand
assembled at the VW plant in Brussels
only 5,000 units were made
VW wanted to get back into rally driving
and for homologation or qualification
purposes needed a commercially available
sports version of the Gulf to
the Gulf to entered its first rally in
1986
Kenneth Erickson of Sweden took the
group a world championship title in a
GTI
but the front-wheel-drive an aspirated
engine were more of a handicap for the
193 horsepower GTI even back then the
speedy group B cars were all
turbocharged and equipped with all-wheel
drive and that's what the Gulf rally had
to have these that forget I'm on the
road going Gulf rally had 160 horsepower
recalls Kristof that far from impressive
performance however was applied very
efficiently and harmoniously even in the
lower Rev ranges VW Zone synchro
four-wheel drive system gave it traction
and a central viscous coupling
distributed the power quite flexibly
between the front and rear axles as
required if I tried to cough Jennifer
Dawkins flexibility fought on ten dogs
in the Gulf rally boasted
state-of-the-art technology it was the
first production model golf2 with abs as
standard a rear spoiler for enhanced
aerodynamics was obligatory
so fix that kind of exclusivity and
technical sophistication had his price
points out Christophe the 1989 Gulf
rally started at 26,000 360 dollars
which was some eleven thousand dollars
more than the 129 horsepower GTI and too
much for even the most obsessive fans a
year later the price was cut to under 20
thousand dollars to get the five
thousand units out on the streets today
the rally model is the most expensive
Gulf - you can buy you'll need at least
15,000 euros to get one in good
condition prefixes a kettle is not the
easiest way to spot a Gulf Rally is by
these flared wide-body fenders to make
room for tires up to 205 centimetres
wide
vital for maximum traction a rear
spoiler and side skirts enhance the
aerodynamics while the rectangular
projector headlights are so bright you
can illuminate the darkest woods with it
one trick the VW engineers came up with
to improve the body stiffness was simply
to glue the windshield in rather than
set it into rubber trim all in all these
were ideal ingredients for rally driving
any pista of course the rally package
includes a stiffer suspension the
special edition golf dispensed with a
low underbody so popular at the time
this uncompromising sports model was
produced solely as a three-door all
add-on parts like the radiator grille
bumpers and side skirts were painted in
the same color as the rest of the car
Recaro bucket seats give aggressive
drivers plenty of stability the
speedometer goes up to 260 km/h making
you curious about what the big bad gulf
has under its hood
yeah
eins Akuma he then newly launched
Corrado's 1.8 liter four-cylinder engine
was slimmed down for the Gulf Rally so
it could compete in one point seven
liter class rallies this G loader scroll
type supercharger provides plenty of
power where other turbochargers are
driven by the exhaust gas this one has a
belt the big advantage is that there's
no turbo lag you get power quickly
however high or low you're revving the
supercharger is designed more like a
compressor than a turbocharger this
supercharger produces lots of power so
it's poor reputation is undeserved I
guess tequilla the supercharger is
robust and with proper care is designed
to last for several hundred thousand
kilometers christoph blamed its bad
reputation on too many people trying too
many crazy tuning experiments it was
easy to soup up the revs but when a
supercharger shaft designed for a
maximum of ten thousand revs suddenly
jumps to fifteen thousand it's hardly
surprising if it goes haywire at some
point d1 yeah that's gadot
dan le Goff crafted the golf rally made
for a real racing car feeling Volkswagen
only built 5,000 of them this
technological pioneer is the
top-of-the-line golf - it's a
collector's item and the most widely
sought after gulf of them all and that
in itself makes it a milestone of
automotive history
good day telecoil is definitely at my
understand the automobile system much of
the Gulf rally's innovative technology
was adapted to VW's mass-produced models
the most powerful version of the later
go free model the vr6 2.9 went into
production in 1994 it came solely with
all-wheel drive